I can't even tell you the amount of
hours it was a year and a half before I
started shooting that I was rehearsing
every day and six months of that time
was was when the movie shut down for
covet because Tom Hanks got covered Tom
Hanks was like the first person first
American to get coveted you were like I
think three days before starting
shooting then the movie shuts down and
suddenly I had six months where it was
just me in my room by myself I
wallpapered my entire apartment with
images of Elvis from different time
periods
move it I was an amazing singing coach
and dialect coach and my movement coach
a karate instructor I lived this for two
years I put the rest of my life on pause
and then getting specific and just
obsessing about one thing like it might
be the way he said one word and I would
just spent all day just obsessing about
this one word when I finished uh I mean
it was an existential crisis afterwards
you know like what is who am I what is
reality all that kind of stuff
foreign